I want to know was there ever talk about
resolving who is the voice in the film
or am I supposed to know who the voices
know because you looked at me like you
should know who the voice is I'm like
what do I know
no no and there was no there was talk
yeah I mean there was moments and where
we were going to do the big reveal of
the voice and we were thinking circling
people at the time who might be the
reveal of the voice but we were also as
the movie was taking shape we were
getting when with these other cameos
were coming in it was like the movie
didn't need more characters and there
was something that I was liking about as
the movie was gelling and post is that
there's this bigger theme of like tech
not which is a classic game in comic
books and you know it's like technology
versus humanity AI vs you know old
school and you know maybe it was best to
just leave this computer voice be a
computer voice it's a mystery and is it
a computer is it a is it how on steroids
is it the Cameo you're not expecting in
the next movie like I thought it was
better and left that then oh look at
another cameo these jackasses brought so
cable it's an interesting choice though
because nowadays everything is revealed
yeah so it's like I can't think of the
last movie that was like no you know
we're not going to tell you know we
didn't go I didn't want to at the end of
the day and I think that it was just
better for the movie so